I don't Parramatta for me to be hosting
thank you very much for having me this
is actually joint project with Andre
Fradkin who's actually sitting here and
he's attending the entire workshop so
feel free to talk to me or Andre okay
I'm really glad Susan presented before
me because she actually introduced the
overall issue of trying to understand
quality of service providers online and
whether we need the government to sort
of step in and regulate and standardize
quality to sort of protect consumers
from risky transactions so this
particular project is related to one
specific type of regulation occupational
licensing occupational licensing
actually imposes requires service
providers to do some training attend
school pass some exams before being able
to sell their services and currently
about 38% of the US workforce is in
licensed occupations that's quite a
large share it's twice as many as in
labor unions as expected and probably
luckily all states licensed doctors
lawyers some states mostly it's also
licensed teachers and barbers but
sometimes barber licensing is even
longer than police training and some
states go all the way to licensing
fortune-tellers auctioneers and interior
designers and fog farmers I heard so of
course proponents of occupational
licensing argue that by restricting
service providers by limiting the
ability of service providers with low
quality from coming in and selling their
services
occupational licensing actually insures
minimum quality levels on the other hand
licensing may restrict competition and
increase prices as a result yep
for researchers PhD no I don't think so
but like we we currently don't we have
peer reviews that sort of allow us to
exactly so exactly so that the
theoretical model that we have in mind
is actually that of Shapiro and the idea
is that occupational licensing may
actually be beneficial for consumers who
actually value high quality at the cost
of consumers who actually value low
prices but in a world where we have
alternative reputation mechanisms like
the peer review system occupational
licensing regulation may not be needed
okay and so that's exactly what we have
in mind when we think about this problem
in in online markets okay we're going to
study these these the setting of
occupational licensing in online
marketplaces which are particularly
important for at least three reasons
they are becoming a primary way to find
professionals in many industries it's
almost the primary way to find write to
go to the airport but it's gone it's
actually a primary way for finding
professionals in many other occupations
in our context it's home improvement
occupations second reason why online
platforms are important is they track
transactions and reviews potentially
making some licensing requirements less
necessary and finally from the
occupational licensing literature purely
they provide a new way to measure the
effects of Licensing which was not
available before okay
let me describe a little bit the online
platform for home improvement services
that we have in mind but just so that
our research questions are sort of clear
we have two related but separate
questions in mind the first one is
trying to understand how consumers value
licensing information when choosing
providers in particular how important is
knowing that a professional is licensed
compared to for example their prices and
their online reputation the rating
system as a preview of the results will
show perhaps expose not surprisingly
that reviews and prices tend to matter a
lot more when choosing professional
online then knowing whether a
professional is licensed ok the second
related question is sort of at the
market level what are the effects of
stricter licensing on competition prices
and entry and so to study this question
we really exploit the fact that
occupations within home improvements are
regulated at the state level and there's
quite a bit of variation across States
and across occupations in the stringency
level of these regulations to show that
stricter regulation tends to lead to
less competition and higher prices and
no measurable effects on what we can
measure of customer satisfaction I
should preempt any questions of sorrow'
it's not necessarily quality it's what
the customer can measure through online
rating and the propensity to come back
to the platform and post again so I'm
gonna go ahead and introduce the
platform which wishes to remain
anonymous but hopefully I'll be as clear
as possible as to what this platform
does
it's like Airbnb for home improvement
services right so if you have if you
need a plumber or you need an
electrician or you need a painter you
can search for the
platforms these help online and
typically this platform is gonna show up
as one of the top results on on Google
you can host a detailed job request and
the details are actually incentivized by
a series of questions that the platform
creates specifically for each service
individually providers are going to
receive these job requests and they are
going to decide whether they are willing
to pay the platform to submit up quote
so the business model is not really a
commission fee it's based on whether a
professional decide system made a quote
and the reason is mostly because it's
very difficult to track these
transactions from the matching to the
end of the service being exchanged
because oftentimes these can take months
and at the end the customer can choose
to hire a pro so a professional so if
you were a customer and you had received
quotes from all the quarter's in in the
in the project you would probably see
something similar to what you're saying
on the slide you would see the number of
the average rating you would see a price
if with an hourly price or with a total
price and of course the quoted price is
not binding in the sense that oftentimes
in home improvement services the price
gets bargained afterwards and
what's also important is that if the
professional is licensed and this has
decided to submit the licensing
information to the platform the
professional is going to have a license
badge on their profile okay and this is
critical so I'll go ahead and sort of
describe how these license badge appears
on the platform because it's part of our
estimation technique of the value of
Licensing okay so to have a license
badge the professional is free to submit
proof of license they don't have to but
if they submit proof of license what the
platform does is take some variable time
to verify the license using information
available on government website so
they'll probably have a license number
the name of the professional who's
licensed and they'll go to the
government website and verify that the
license is actually current up-to-date
and hasn't expired okay the platform as
I mentioned take some variable time and
talking to the employees at at the
platform these variable time does not
depend on a specific occupation
necessarily does not depend on things
that are related to the beador's or the
jobs that the B there is submitting
requests for and it can take from the
average time is five and a half days but
there's quite a bit of standard
deviation so I can take from a few days
two most common licenses in these in
these marketplace are the licenses that
you would expect if you've ever needed
help in your in your home contractors
plumbers electricians home inspectors
pest control
pesticide applicator and others okay we
have so yes and no let me give you a
couple of specific examples in
California actually painters are
required to have a license if they work
on jobs that are more than five hundred
dollars in Florida you know you can call
yourself interior designer if you're not
licensed to be an interior designer but
you are free to call yourself interior
decorator at that point you don't need
to be licensed so there are clear rules
for specific names and for specific job
titles and specific levels of job
complexity as determined by the price
but on this platform you both have jobs
for less than five painting jobs for
less than $500 and painting jobs for
more than five hundred dollars and you
have interior decorators and interior
designers what's the legal liability of
the home no legal liability in the sense
that they are actually just they
facilitate the matching between the
buyer and the seller but they are not
involved in the transaction so they
provide the information that a buyer
needs help professionals pay to submit
the beds but the ultimate person who is
responsible for their licensing
requirement is the provider
the state will not sue them if they help
like painters subvert the law they're
hoping they want me soon Yelp where the
difference is that you as the buyer can
actually post requests but can't imagine
a quarry for the designer for mr.
Corkery for designer interior decorator
they don't match anybody they only send
the request to all the bidders and the
bidders self-select into whether they
can submit a bed and whether they want
to submit a bid everyone there are
within a specific category yes but so
it's actually ultimately the choice of
the professional to submit a bid for a
particular job and be responsible that
they are legally able to perform the
service for that particular job on the
on the quote so if the professional
decides to submit a bed for your
specific job the professional pays a
fixed amount of money to the flower so
the bathroom doesn't necessarily track
the transaction until the end it's just
like a personalized listing exactly yeah
yep I see some old are you ensure that
your
so oftentimes the licensing regulation
has some of these requirements but again
it's up to the professional to have
insurance if the state requires that you
have insurance to practice yeah and
oftentimes the occupational licensing
regulation requires you to have
insurance yeah so the only the only role
of the platform is verifying that if you
say that you are a licensed plumber
plumber in California your name and your
license number shows up in the
California records for plumbers that's
the only role that the platform
verification okay so we have data from
from this platform confidential data
from the platform we have about eight
months in 2015 some longer but we mostly
focus on these eight months period
because we have two important dates for
our identification strategy that they 20
professional submits proof of license
and debate when the license of the
professional is verified by the platform
and so visible to the consumers we have
many different service categories within
home improvement in the platform is
present in all 50 states and we have a
few million bids submitted on the
thousands of of jobs and we have date up
at the bit level at the request level
and at the pro level and all of them
will be helpful so let me start by sort
of asking whether consumers care about
knowing that a professional is licensed
on the platform okay
and we take advantage of the fact that
there is some time lag between the time
when a professional decides to submit
proof of license which may be correlated
with a lot of other unobserved quality
that the platform had that the
professional has
there's some time lag within between
that time and the time when the
professional is verified and so their
licensing badge is submitted is visible
to the consumer so we're going to look
at one particular outcome we'll look at
other outcomes and in follow-up event
studies we're gonna look at the
probability of being hired as a function
of whether you were showing a license
badge or not okay so if you look at the
time when the license is verified okay
before this time the licensing badge is
not visible on your profile and after
the licensing badge is visible on your
profile and this time is sort of
exogenous conditional on the time I have
quite a stringent set of controls but
the results are sort of there even if we
don't take into account sort of
selection into requests or we're gonna
look at the coefficients of interest
which are determined that the week
relative to the license verification
okay so if we look and these are sort of
the the the quantities the estimates
here our percentage points okay
increases in the probability of being
hired okay if you look at the
probability of being hired before and
after the license is verified you can
see that both the point estimate and
sort of the confidence intervals are
relatively the queenís mean is low and
the confidence intervals are relatively
large and they always include the zero
now it may be that we don't see an
effect of Licensing verified on your
probability of being hired because all
of a sudden you know that you are
verified and so you start bidding higher
prices okay so there may be supply
responses that sort of counteract this
additional benefit of having the license
verified and so we can look at other
outcomes for example the
the submitted price that you submit
before and after your licensing badge
appears on your profile and again we
don't see that you all of a sudden
submit higher bids for jobs the moment
your license is verified
we have other supply responses that we
can measure and sort of we don't see any
additional supplier responses on quote
speed so it the the faster you are as
submitting quotes the higher the chances
that you are getting hired we don't see
that you are in any way faster or slower
after the license is verified and you
seem to submit bids for requests they
have a similar composition of
competitors okay so similar number of
competitors and the similar amounts
quoted by competing bidders okay now
just to show you that yep sorry it's
outside option because we many times
licensed contractors they don't go for
the platform but I learn about them from
colleagues and make maybe once you're in
the platform if you're looking in the
platform because you care just about
prices or like getting us ideal but
maybe a professional license contract
outside yeah so here you have to have
higher the clicked on the higher button
on the platform the short answer is in
terms of outside option we don't know
how different the outside options are
for different consumers here we look at
whether the consumer hi click the button
on whether they actually hired up of the
professional typically they hire I think
we have that higher dummy for about six
percent of our requests so it's not a
huge amount and it's sort of a large
underestimate of the actual matches that
we think are happening through the
platform
but it's not that that consumer sort of
high click on these higher bottom button
for multiple professionals for a given
request so if they click on it it tends
to be somebody that they've selected to
sort of communicate further about the
the service but again no idea about the
outside option yeah so slightly related
maybe and what's the fraction of people
that do have licensed or not to sort of
see in all the time of the attraction
whether it's a good source of non
licensure I don't remember the fraction
related your first questions we did a
survey of people that are buying
improvement services and their
preferences at least from the survey
very similar regardless of whether they
find a professional through friends or
online or another service and then the
higher rates start and then the sorry
the licensed verified rates are around
twelve percent or so but they're they're
likely many more licensed professionals
on the platform that have never gotten
their license verified by the fund so I
I have a story in my head and I'm
curious whether you think it's like a
plausible story so I need a plumber I
want someone who's licensed but I also
believe that people are generally
following the law and therefore that
wherever I find on the platform is
likely to be licensed whether it's
listed or not yeah and you're
anticipating where we're headed
so one possibility for why we don't see
any effect of the sort of of the signal
of the licensing badge is that everybody
trusts that the if you're submitting a
quote it's because you know that you
should be licensed and so we just trust
that you're just following the law and
in that case assuming that can help us
look at sort of the effect of stricter
licensing on competition and prices but
doesn't matter it's just
indication absolutely yeah it's just
this is this is not and I should be
clear about that this is not the that
licensing regulation doesn't matter
it's the signalling value of the
licensing badge is zero now just to show
you that the sort of event study
approach actually works with alternative
components of quality that consumers
take into account when choosing
providers we can do the same event study
approach with the submission of the
first review okay so today extended the
submission of the first review is it's
not under the control of the service
provider providers we can look at before
and after we tend to see a pre trend
here it's easily explained by the fact
that they're the first review might be
submitted after the quote is submitted
but before the consumer hires a pro and
so once we take these time lag between
the quote summation time and the hiring
decision time the pre trend sort of
disappears and note that the point
estimate here is a lot larger because
now here we need to consider only tasks
that have at least one hired
professional we can look at supply
responses here we do see a large effect
in the total number of beds that are
professional submits but not in the
composition of beds that the
professional submits so the moment of
professional receives a first review
they are much more active on the site
but they tend to bed about the same
price and two requests that have a
similar competitors okay now we can do
this we can show these in a choice
regressions I'm not going to show you
the results but it's sort of important
to understand really the three
components that affect choices prices
online reviews and and license verified
and you know all three of these have
sort of endogeneity issues that we try
to tackle in three different ways first
the licensing information
we can we can really use the time lag
between submission and validation to
really look at the impact of the
licensing badger appearing on the
website conditional on the fact that
you've decided to submit proof of
license price we can instrument and we
have sort of a strong first stage we can
instrument with the geographic distance
between the professional and the
consumers and to the extent that the
distance affects your cost of providing
services to a particular customer
without affecting directly the
propensity that the customer chooses you
this is sort of a valid instrument and
then we have online reviews which we
sort of take a slightly different
approach to the instruments
instrumentation strategy that Susan
described earlier we basically adopt
sort of this jackknife approach sort of
we instrument for vocal professionals
rating we the stringency that consumers
applied while rating professionals other
than the focal okay so if you end up
being rated by customers that tend to be
stricter in the rating then you're more
likely to have a lower rating and I'm
not going to show you the results but we
have similar results as the event study
and we tend to find highly price
sensitive consumers and this is
important
exactly in the world that I introduced
at the beginning of Shapiro where we're
really sort of with occupational
licensing regulation we tend to benefit
consumers who care about high quality at
the expense of consumers who care about
low prices and Rea sort of added to this
hinted that there's at the survey
evidence of course I cannot tell you the
platform that we're getting the data
from so how large is this platform are
the sort of external validity questions
are sort of obvious at this point so
we've decided to
run a survey of about 5,000 consumers
who recently hired for home improvement
services they hired in the last year and
really we wanted to check what consumers
know and think and so we use an
independent survey company and these are
respondents that use the Internet to
answer these surveys so it was an online
survey but it should be a nationally
representative survey pool of
respondents we asked them how they find
professionals and this is where it's
sort of important for just the role of
these platforms we find that about 16%
of the survey respondents have found
help through a platform like ours
oftentimes the 25% of the people who
find help through Google or Yelp
actually end up in a platform like ours
so if we some shares we get to 40% share
of consumers using online sources to
find home improvement professionals so
it's quite substantial the sort of
word-of-mouth and referral from a
friendly skilled among them sort of the
top reasons for hiring professionals
cost and prices are always top of their
mind they also care about quality
quality reviews recommendation and
Friends less than 1% of them mentioned
licenses we also asked them about sort
of what they know about licensing
regulation do they know whether the
professional is licensed typically they
know that but they don't know it at the
time of search they find out when they
sign the contract or they find out
because of Cheeta
them but they didn't really verify it
our consumers even aware of the
licensing requirements for the
particular require need that they have
about 50% of them think that the license
is required for the particular need that
they have
now it's they think that the license is
required we cannot directly verify
whether it's the belief is correct many
of them have no idea
so about 38% of them actually have no
idea whether the license whether a
license is required for the job they are
hiring for but many of them just trust
the government back to next point they
just trust that the licensing regulation
is is good to the point that about 53%
of them are in favor of licensing
regulation okay so because consumers
tend to trust the the regulation that is
in place to protect them from risky
transactions we can actually look at
whether these regulation increases the
prices that they face and limits the
competition that they the number of
providers that they can get services
from okay so we look at aggregate
outcomes we exploit the fact that we
have different occupations and different
states with different levels of
regulation okay
so let's assume that we have a measure
of Licensing stringency I'll tell you in
a second what that measure is and an
occupation we particular outcomes in the
matching stage in the transaction stage
and in post transaction stage to look at
whether consumers face higher quotes or
lower quotes as a function of the
licensing stringency whether consumers
face higher lower quoted prices as a
function of
stringency whether they are in any way
whether they have a higher lower
probability of being hired and the
winning quote and finally whether they
are more satisfied with their match as
measured by the probability of living a
five-star review or the probability of
posting again so we actually Steve has
shown that there is externality the
propensity of views of users to come
back to the platform as a function of
the previous interactions that they've
had with particular service so what is
this measure of Licensing stringency we
don't have it from the platform we have
to collect additional data to do that we
rely heavily on the Institute for
justice license to work database which
is in its second edition and a lot more
detailed than the first edition they
have information on fees exams minimum
grade age education and experience that
are required to practice in about a
hundred low skilled occupations across
the u.s. for electricians plumbers and
general contractors for some reasons
these occupations are not in the
Institute for justice database and so we
hand collected the same level of
information by phoning or emailing and
then we derive a one dimensional score
by a principal component analysis so
just to show you at first what our
licensing stringency sort of our first
component component is most correlated
with it tends to be correlated with fees
with number of days lost so this is a
number that the Institute for justice
creates to sort of estimate how many
days do you
as a function of all the stringency
requirements that the particular
occupation in the particular state in
which you are required and so it's
highly correlated with that the number
of exams minimum age experience and
minimum grade now because these
licensing stringency measure doesn't
mean much to you let me show you what
what the occupation with the average
licensing stringent see requires it's
sort of painters in Oregon who have to
be 18 years old have to pay three
hundred and eighty five dollars in
licensing fees they have 16 o'clock
hours of instruction so a couple of days
and they have to pass one exam now add
one standard deviation to this to these
licensing stringency which brings us to
electricians in Connecticut now they
have to be as old they have to pay twice
as much in licensing fees almost twice
as much they have to have two years of
experience not two days of instruction
and past three exams so there is quite a
bit of changes in the levels of
Licensing strangers so all of these
coefficients are again sort of should be
interpreted as a one standard deviation
in licensing strange and see how does it
affect the outcome variable of interest
okay and so if we look at the number of
quotes we can see yes even if I wanted
to be like personally wouldn't have to
do any licensing maybe I still need two
years of experience to know what I'm
doing
absolutely but it's not the government
that imposes that on you and so you may
need two years of experience but
somebody else may need only six months
so isn't that like how do you compare
it's two years of experience for
electrician more than two days for
painter
if you think about so ultimately we
don't compare these against this we
compare just our licensing stringency
measure which is a composition of all of
this like the stringency that it's just
due to the technical knowledge or the
job or isn't it so yeah so and we some
occupations tend to have tend to require
longer longer training more exams but
that should be captured in sort of so at
that point we take advantage of the of
the fact that for a given occupation in
Nevada you have last year's of training
than in California and so if you think
that people in Nevada need for other
reasons more training than then you can
discuss it offline but we we're not
we're not these is just to tell you like
to interpret these coefficients here so
what is a one standard deviation
increase example in volume two examples
and electricians in the US and they talk
to example in stream you see yep
you wouldn't get one standard deviation
necessarily but yeah most likely thank
you okay so now back to the results so I
want one no deviation increasing these
licensing stringent see again may not
happen within a particular occupation
but it reduces the number of coats by
2.4 percent it increases the quoted
price by 3.2 percent has no effect on
matching probability so it's not that
you are more likely to match with
licensed professionals when the
licensing stringency is higher but still
it increases the winning quote by 2.5%
sort of these increase in the quoted
price translates into increase in the
winning quote and we just cannot measure
any effect on customer satisfaction
measures even anything actually the
coefficient is negative the size of the
coefficient means just now it is
possible that the the the tasks the
composition of tasks change across
states and occupations and so we can we
could be capturing here something else
that has to do with the fact that maybe
in states and occupations where the
licensing stringency is higher the type
of jobs the complexity of the jobs it is
also is also higher but we have a
detailed set of questions and answers
that actually the consumer answers when
posting the job and so we can sort of
predict both our treatment variable and
our outcome variable in a double machine
double machine learning framework and
sort of regress the residuals on the
treatment variable the residuals on the
app of the outcome variable on the
residuals of the treatment vary
to see whether the coefficients change
once we control for these very rich set
of features that describe the task
characteristics and we just basically
I'm I'm not showing the results it
basically gives the same results both in
statistical sense and now we can perform
should be different also windows more
license things so can you eject that
it's just at the outside option being
off the platform is more attractive
windows more licensing so it would have
to change at the occupation and state
level it actually zip code not just
state because we have space attacks
against ort of control for geography
characteristics that are common across
occupations and occupation
characteristics that may be common
across geographies
okay so now it may be from a consumers
perspective that you're particularly
worried about licensing requirements and
quality if you have a more complex job
then if you have a lacks complex job a
less complex job so how do we proxy for
complexity we can sort of predict the
price point of your job by training a
machine learning algorithm that predicts
sort of the expected average bed that
you would be receiving given the
characteristics of your of your request
given where you live and we sort of
estimated we predicted out of samples so
we we divide the sample into sort of
five sub samples of 20% of the data each
and we predict the prices of the 20% on
the rest of the 80% and so we can look
at the effect of licensing stringency
interacted with whether your job is
predicted to receive at least bids
higher than $200 and we can see that
most of the effect of the licensing
stringency goes through a bigger effect
on price for these more complex jobs so
one standard deviation is licensee
increases matched quote by 7% for jobs
above $200 by 12 percent in jobs for
above $500 and all the way to 17 percent
in jobs that are estimated to receive
bit above thousand dollars so it seems
that the licensing stringency has a
bigger effect
so again to sort of conclude and go back
to the results that I hinted at at the
beginning we've shown with an event
study approach with survey evidence and
with some regression analysis that's
reviews and prices seem to matter more
than knowing where the professional is
hired now at the market level we find
that more stringent licensing regimes
lead to less competition and and higher
prices and we don't have detectable
effects on the probability of coming
back to the platform or leaving a
five-star review and so hopefully this
is an input a useful piece of
information on the undercurrent debate
on occupational licensing regulation
which says that licensing right
[Applause]
the provider right because you saw unit
price and rating and then if you click
the new season charge even you move the
value formation you next okay what would
happen to your question so we the way
the platform showed that these
information was relatively stable
throughout the period of our of the data
that we're using so but we don't know
whether making certain pieces of
information more or less prominent has
has an effect there's research that has
shown that if you if you make Italian it
become salient but we don't know
the ratings matter less so we tried we
actually have some of the event studies
we can break them down by whether you've
received reviews before or not the
estimates are overall very noisy but
depending on our cuts the majority of
our cuts basically show that why
something doesn't matter there are some
cuts where you see a little bit of an
effect but if you really sort of mind
the data for hit Virginia's effect okay
so that's out as far as you know we have
a larger 830 and
[Music]
[Applause]